all right y'all when I find something on
social media that's super cute I want to
share it with you this is what I'm
liking so you never know when your kids
might stumble upon the next great idea
like who would have thought that a
four-year-old girl bringing a chicken
into her cheer routine which totally
makes sense would take the Internet by
storm but indeed it has 5 six seven
eight 1 2 3 4 5 six 7
that Instagram post has
32.5 million views and Counting they are
impressed by The Chicken Dance uh we
have the young cheerleader on the line
right now along with her mama watching
on
kxxv hi Fallon hi
kall hi kie thank you so much for having
us oh my gosh you are so cute so Kendall
how did this happen so we got chickens
around the same time she started
cheerleading she begged for cheer for a
long time we finally put her in and then
we got chickens too so she started
spending lots of time outside with them
and just combined the two loves that she
had and I turned around one day and she
was stunting her chicken I was like
that's actually a really solid routine
so I recorded it and posted it and
that's when it just took off it was
crazy so what what would Kelsey say to
you do you think Fallon I love you a oh
my God you are so
cute oh you make me want have babies Oh
but I don't want to do that anymore okay
um I love you Fallon your name is so
awesome too Mama way to go on the name
that's such a cool first name um so do
you you have a new cheer don't
you yeah do you want to show me your
cheer yeah
[Applause]
yes oh there we
go yeah
Dad five six
1 2 3 4 five
6 you are incredible Fallon you're so
cool Fallon thank you for joining
us thank you Valen thank you Kendall and
Kelsey of course I'm liking y'all's post
right now look how gent oh my God you're
so cute way to go mama
a okay so that's not all our season long
partner pilot pin makers of G2 the go-to
pin of the Kelly Clarkson show want to
honor truly Unstoppable people that just
rad like you so they're going to be
riding you a check for $1,000 how's that
sound oh my
God thank you so much thank you guys so
much you have made me have the greatest
day ever Fallon I love you sweetheart
thank you for joining us and thank you
to all our guests this hour Neil the
tyon Bernie pin Dylan and Atlanta Smet
youall have a great day it it's not try
and change
[Music]
[Applause]
it thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home